on the 19th of June the Ocean Gate
submersible began its descent to the
Titanic's fractured remains here in the
Northwestern Atlantic with a descent
rate of 55 meters per minute it would
take the submersible 70 minutes to reach
its destination with each passing minute
the equivalent of 5.3 atmospheres of
pressure would be added to the subs Hull
by the time it reached its Target depth
the weight of 366 of Earth's atmospheres
would be attempting to crush it
apply to an area a little larger than an
A3 piece of paper that's equivalent to
the thrust of a Saturn V F1 engine
pressing in from all directions an hour
and 45 minutes into the dive at the
bottom of the ocean 3 800 meters down
with this immense pressure bearing down
on a tall the Ocean Gate submersible
lost contact with the surface
we now know the submersible imploded a
sudden catastrophic collapse a tragic
accident however any composite material
engineer could have predicted this
failure and they did I worked as a
composite design engineer and completed
my master thesis in composite failure
prediction so let's dive into the
questionable engineering decisions that
Ocean Gate made that led to a tragic
accident
with that pressure comes some Extreme
Design challenges ocean Gates Titan
submersible consists of Two titanian end
caps one with a large acrylic window
joined to a filament wound carbon fiber
reinforced epoxy Hull inside the
submersible is pretty bare bone some
screens that are fed data from cameras
from the outside and the four electric
thrusters are controlled with from what
I can tell a third-party GameCube
controller
many people are focusing on this part of
the design but that's the least of my
concerns we will be focusing on One
Design aspect of this submersible the
composite hole carbon fiber Composites
aren't really known for their
compressive strength they work best in
tension great for airplanes that are
pressurized from the inside where the
pressure inside the fuselage Works to
expand the circular cross-section
putting the fibrous in tension for a
submarine the pressure will work to
compress the hull placing the fibers
primarily in compression this
immediately set off alarm bells in my
mind when I heard of the missing
submarine so I began digging into their
justification for using the material
Ocean Gate chose this carbon fiber
composite primarily to benefit from its
natural buoyancy these type of Subs
actually want to be as close to
neutrally buoyant as possible meaning
the weight of water they displace weighs
about the same as the vehicle itself
minimizing The energy needed to rise or
sink in the water this means to surface
in an emergency they don't need power
they just drop ballasts that make them
positively buoyant and they just float
to the surface the carbon fiber
composite can be lighter and thus helps
achieve this neutral buoyancy Target
typically submarine holes are made from
steel or more recently titanium but in
order to achieve the desired buoyancy
they need foam outer layers Ocean Gate
CEO Stockton Rush who was inside the
submersible stated that they wanted to
skip this foam layer because it added to
costs that isn't necessarily an evil
thing if the composite is up for the job
this is where things get iffy Ocean Gate
had no idea where there was up to the
task or not and we know this because
they admit it in their own blog post
justifying their decision to not test
the vehicle with a regulatory body the
now removed block entry reads most
marine operators require that chartered
vessels are classed by an independent
group classing assures ship owners
insurers and Regulators that vessels are
designed constructed and inspected to
accept its standards classing may be
effective at filtering out
unsatisfactory designers and Builders
but the established standards do little
to weed out so power vessel operators
the vast majority of marine and Aviation
accidents are a result of operator air
not mechanical failure as a result
simply focusing on classing The Vessel
does not address the operational risks
now I would have thought this wouldn't
need pointing out but the fact this
glaring red flag has been written on
their own website for everyone to see
and several extremely wealthy and
successful people didn't seem to think
it was an issue seems to suggest
otherwise
perhaps most submarine accidents occur
due to operator air precisely because
they have undergone rigorous testing and
certification the comparison to Aviation
is just a wild kind of worms that we
have very recent catastrophic accidents
to compare to where manufacturers
willfully circumvented regulatory
procedures these earned procedures
created as some kind of unnecessary
inconvenience to inventors they are very
useful guidelines and testing procedures
to prove that you've not missed some
catastrophic failure mode in your design
and that's exactly what happened one
failure mode is unique to Composite
Materials in deep sea applications some
of the first evidence we got for it was
in glass fiber reinforced deep sea
piping it's called Snap buckling or
delamination coupled bottling failure
mode for thin walled pressure vessels
the failure mode is simply buckling
where the pressure simply caves the
entire wall in but here because the wall
thickness is so large to deal with the
immense pressure of the deep sea the
failure mode gets more complicated this
failure mode is characterized by
delamination of the internal layer of
the pressure vessel basically the inside
of the pressure vessel suddenly peels
away from the rest of the wall leading
to a catastrophic failure of the overall
structure and the exact mechanisms of
this failure mode are not entirely well
understood as stated in this 2022
research paper titled a review of
structural failure of composite pressure
hulls in deep sea it states in its
conclusion investigations on this
subject have remained at theoretical
level there are still very little
research in this area in recent years so
I am assuming whoever engineered this
pressure vessel did at least the same
level of research as a YouTuber who
wrote a script on the subject in two
days they must have at least been aware
of this problem a failure mode like this
is going to be exacerbated by gradual
damage incurred by cyclical stresses
like those experienced when diving to
depths of 4 000 meters and resurfacing
again they have done that at least 50
times with this vessel without ever
fatigue testing it per their own
admission they did not undergo industry
standard classifications but they did do
their own classification test one test
stated on that blog post once again a
licensed marine surveyor will witness a
successful dive to 4000 meters inspect
the vessel before and after the dive and
provide a statement of fact attesting to
the completion of the dive test plan
that is simply not adequate anything
undergoing repeated stress Cycles like
this needs to be fatigue tested like the
test airplane manufacturers do on wings
where they Flex the plane's wings
thousands of times on the ground they
designed this thing essentially with
computer modeling with no real world
testing composite materials are
incredibly difficult to model in
computer software composite materials
are far more complicated than
homogeneous material materials like
steel where the material properties are
the same in all directions and in all
regions of the material Composites are
composed of fibers bound together by a
matrix material like epoxy if we were to
zoom into a small cross-section of this
we may see something like this some
fibers some of them could be touching
without any Matrix between them some
could be spaced further apart and there
can also be empty voids that the epoxy
didn't manage to fill
we can simulate a small section like
this independently to help analyze some
failure modes such as delamination
however if we want to zoom out and test
a larger section we often need to
average the material properties in some
way or else the simulation will take too
long to run my own Master thesis tried
to combine the two by embedding a fiber
and Matrix cell within an averaged
composite material there are specialized
softwares that can model different fiber
orientations but they are still very
much an estimation you need to back this
up with physical testing something ocean
gaze didn't do there are more signs of
incompetent use of Composites for a
critical structure like this I would
very much recommend curing it in an
autoclave that's basically a pressurized
oven that helps push those voids I
mentioned earlier out of the epoxy resin
autoclades are expensive and it can be
difficult to find Once large enough to
fit something like this but it's nice to
not have air bubbles in a pressure
vessel keeping you alive however an
autoclave was not used for this pressure
vessel it was simply bagged and cured a
cheaper alternative Spencer Composites
was commissioned to make the composite
hole and their CEO was interviewed back
in 2017 in a Composites World article he
seems very aware of the immense design
challenge he has been handed and he does
mention that the porosity of the cured
pressure vessel was assessed to be less
than one percent less than one percent
voids doesn't exactly Inspire confidence
is it 0.99 or is it 0.001 porosity
that's exactly the type of defect that's
going to increase the risk of snap
buckling as voids can be a propagation
site for delamination the blog post goes
on to dismiss classification tests as
unsuitable for Innovative designs which
is complete narcissistic nonsense this
isn't Innovative they have made a
pressure vessel from a carbon fiber
composite using known manufacturing
practices and started charging rich
people 250 000 to risk their lives in it
Innovation would be creating that
pressure vessel and testing it figuring
out the causes of snap buckling and
advancing Material Science For All
Mankind this is profiteering not
innovation
to eliminate all doubts that this
company has willfully ignored safety
standards this court case from 2018 was
brought against Ocean Gate by a former
employee who was fired shortly after
raising concerns about the composite
Hull stating that not enough was done to
check for delaminations and voids Ocean
Gate argued that the technology to check
for voids and delaminations in a
composite this thick did not exist and
instead they would use their acoustic
monitoring system which essentially
listens for the sounds of fracture to
predict failure but this is what a
carbon fiber composite fracture curve
looks like it's a cliff Edge sudden
catastrophic collapse an acoustic
monitoring system like this is akin to
setting up a camera to warn you thunder
is coming you will see the lightning
before the Thunder but the time between
them is minimal this is pure safety
theater
it gets even worse on one test dive in
the Bahamas a submersible expert could
hear the cracking with his own ears and
warned Stockton Rush that it was a sign
of damage accumulating Stockton once
again chose to ignore an expert advice
so this acoustic monitoring system was
purely for marketing purposes to give
customers who don't have the engineering
background to see through it a false
sense of security I would attribute this
to malice and greed but Stockton Rush
chose to Pilot this death trap himself
as hanlon's razor goes never attribute
to malice that which can be attributed
to stupidity
there is a growing Trend in engineering
of moving fast and breaking stuff mostly
driven by one overconfident CEO who has
to be fair to him succeeded in
revolutionizing an entire industry with
that ethos
that incriminating blog post even
mentions SpaceX blue origin and Virgin
Galactic as bastions of innovation for
this move fast and break things Mantra
Virgin Galactic 2 have blood on their
hands with their 2014 in-flight breakup
which was attributed to inadequate
design safeguards and poor pilot
training along with a lack of oversight
from regulatory bodies
this attitude is dangerous and this
won't be the last story of wealthy
narcissistic CEOs putting lives at risk
when a doctor is negligent to the safety
of their patients they are liable from
malpractice but the impact their
incompetence has can affect one patient
when an engineer neglects their
responsibilities it can affect hundreds
thousands maybe even Millions we need
more people like David Lockridge the
employee who was fired for raising
concerns over safety the very first
video on this channel stated our mission
to inspire the next generation of
Engineers but it's about more than just
inspiring Engineers we need Engineers
going into the most impactful Industries
to solve the largest problems facing our
civilization you've probably heard a lot
of career advice Follow Your Passion do
what you love take initiative but a lot
of advice out there doesn't take into
account the best available evidence we
have for what actually makes for a high
impact and fulfill career today's
sponsor 80 000 hours is a non-profit
that for the last 10 years has been
researching the question of how you can
find a fulfilling career that does good
too everything they publish is based on
careful consideration of the data
consultation with experts and taking
into account the best evidence they
could find on the topic and because they
take this evidence-based approach they
are able to make concrete
recommendations on hard questions like
where should I work if I actually want
to make a positive difference in the
world what are the most pressing
problems facing Humanity today and how
might we solve them and what can I do
today to start planning a fulfilling
career they have published over 30
articles on one incredibly pressing
issue safety in the development of AI
they have a website with tons of
collected research on high impact
careers a job board which lists
currently open roles they think might
help you have a positive impact and a
podcast test where they have
conversations with experts about the
world's most pressing problems
everything they provide is free forever
because they're a non-profit their only
aim is to help solve Global Problems by
helping people find the most impactful
careers they can if you join the
newsletter now you'll get a free copy of
their in-depth research-led career guide
sent to your inbox just sign up to 80
000 hours dot org forward slash real
engineering or click on the button on
screen right now